former president trump is heading back
to washington for the first time since
leaving office he's using the
investigation into his actions on
january 6th as a way to rally his
supporters caitlin huey burns is in
washington caitlin good morning
good morning nate well president trump
is expected to headline the america
first agenda summit here in washington
where organizers say he's expected to
lay out a policy agenda for this year's
midterm elections and likely his own
political comeback
donald trump returns to washington in a
similar way to how he left it under a
cloud of scrutiny over the attack on the
u.s capitol for three hours
the defeated former president of the
united states watched it all happen
new video released by the january 6
committee monday shows a draft of
then-president trump's speech on january
7th do you recognize the handwriting
it looks like my father's handwriting it
says he edited out a directive for the
justice department to prosecute
lawbreakers as well as a line that read
the rioters do not represent our
movement the justice department's
investigation is also heating up with
mark short the former vice president's
chief of staff testifying before a
federal grand jury i can confirm that i
did receive a subpoena for the federal
grand jury and i comply with that
subpoena the republican party is the
party of the future this comes as other
republicans including former vice
president mike pence begin to position
themselves for their own white house
bids in 2024. i think it's created space
now for other republicans to look their
hands over and say you know what i'm
like trump but i'm not trump you can
vote for me and get all the good without
all of the bad but trump isn't deterred
hinting at another presidential campaign
if i announced that i was not going to
run for office
the persecution
of donald trump
would immediately stop we know that
everybody knows that there's no chance i
do that there's just no chance i do that
i can't do it
now trump is expected to focus his
speech today on crime and public safety
which will be key issues in this year's
midterm elections also slated to be in
town today former former vice president
mike pence he's speaking to a
conservative student conference vlad
all right we'll be covering it thank you
very much caitlin appreciate it